when we think of all our freedoms that
the radical left wants to take away we
usually think of our right to free
speech or our right to keep and bear
arms or our right to keep our own
property or our right to have a say in
the course of our government
all of those things are at risk but the
radicals who are emboldened after a
successful year and a half of grabbing
power
are now after an even more fundamental
right even more fundamental than all of
those and they're not even hiding it
major democrats in this country
including the governor of virginia are
now claiming that parents have no right
to raise their own kids
the parents had to write
to veto bills veto books glenn not to be
knowledge about it also take them off
the shelves and i'm not going to let
parents come into schools and actually
take votes out and make their own
decision
you vetoed it so
yeah my parents stop the bill that i
don't think parents should be telling
schools what they should teach but
yeah i don't think parents should be
telling schools how their children
should be educated from the age of five
to 18. or really now it's more like
three or four years old until what until
you're out of college 22 or graduate
school or your phd i don't think parents
have any right to determine how kids are
educated for 20 some odd years of their
life according to democrats you no
longer possess that right the right to
raise your own children turns out the
people of virginia don't like that very
much as they made clear last night at a
loudoun county school board meeting i'm
michael knowles it's the michael knowles
show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from jn who says whoa
the new york governor giving a literal
sermon on the public health god that is
science
is one of the creepiest things i've ever
seen a politician do and that's a long
history of creepiness and insanity
i agree it reminds us of something that
has always been true
all politics is religious
sometimes it's more explicitly so but
it's always there all human conflict
ultimately is theological and now you've
got the new governor of new york who got
her job because andy cuomo got booted
out
giving
outright sermons calling on people to be
her apostles for the cult of
progressivism and public health it
really makes you want to be able to do
things
for yourself fix things for yourself
which is why i would strongly recommend
rock auto what kind of car do you have
what year is it what's the model is it
the ex or the fx is it is it the coupe
or is it the four-door or is it the this
or is it the that or is it do you like
being peppered with all these questions
i certainly don't
once you give the answers to these
questions if you even can you know what
the next the next thing you're gonna
hear is in the brick and mortar auto
parts store okay i'm gonna go in the
back see if we have the part you know
what you know what else you're gonna
hear oh we don't have the part then they
go online probably to rockauto.com they
order the part you got to wait a few
days you got to pay twice as much why
would you do that you could just go to
rockauto.com the catalog is so easy to
navigate even i can navigate it the
prices are reliably low same for pros
and do-it-yourselfers family companies
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
it's a no-brainer go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and then write
knowles k-n-o-w-l-e-s
in there how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you when i did
my book reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
number one best-selling blank book
about four years ago still selling like
hotcakes by the way so thank you to
everyone who's giving the gift of
knowledge to themselves and their
friends
when i did that book
some people gave me the title king of
the trolls
okay
and vanity fair
called me a dapper lib triggering troll
and they they thought that this blank
book was a really good troll and i agree
it was fun i enjoyed it
i may need to relinquish my crown
i may need to hand my crown to a
colleague of mine that would be mr matt
walsh who wanted to go speak at a
loudoun county school board meeting this
is a school board meeting in virginia
but he doesn't live in virginia it's not
a big deal you can go to public school
board meetings except that when the
school board found out he was going to
go they had a requirement that you had
to be a virginia resident so what does
matt do is he deterred no he just rents
an apartment
in virginia then he goes there and he
shows up last night and they pulled a
bunch of other shenanigans to try to
keep him out limit what he could say not
stream the speech
but there was a big rally outside
and matt gets up there matt who
you know i guess he's lived in virginia
for a few days now
i'm not sure how much longer he's going
to live in virginia uh he has really
only lived in tennessee for some months
now and we're actually kind of new to
the south in general
but matt gets up on the back of a pickup
truck to give a speech
and the people there chant all the
parents in loudon county
welcome home matt
thank you so much
well
maybe it's not even matt who gets king
of the trolls maybe it is the concerned
parents of loudoun county because they
they got it they went along with it uh
matt you know matt got to go say his
piece i'm glad he did obviously the i
think the the message was clear who
cares what anyone said in the room the
fact that there was a major rally
outside of the school board meeting
frankly that's all you need to know
about the sending the message to the
school board
but
to me what's more interesting than the
critical race theory curriculum
or the kind of radicalism in the schools
or what's more interesting even than
matt going and showing up there
are those parents
who are outside who are cheering on
a
recent
a recent resident of tennessee who
got a place in virginia for a couple of
days they say welcome home matt and
they're playing along what it shows me
is
politics is no longer local in this
country there was an old old expression
tip o'neill former democrat speaker of
the house used to say all politics is
local and that was common sense in
america for a very long time
i don't think that is the case any
longer
occasionally i'll go to a small town i
mean i travel all over the country and
when i'm in a small town i don't always
even see a local paper anymore but
sometimes they'll still have a local
paper and i find it so refreshing it
reminds me of what the country used to
be like 20 years ago not that long ago
and it's got the the local head of the
community and he's writing about the
local issues and we just don't see that
a lot anymore increasingly the issues
that preoccupy our time even in small
town america are national issues you see
this in latin county it's not just that
there's some weird creepy thing going on
in the schools there that's particular
to loudoun county it's that this creepy
thing is going on in the schools all
over the country and that would be the
critical race theory curriculum that
would be the radical gender curriculum
and so you can have a national
conservative media figure like matt
walsh come in there and he's welcomed
like a hometown hero
this is partially i think technological
because you've you've got the
proliferation of the internet and ways
to connect to people now who might be on
the other side of the country or on the
other side of the world
but also you've got a breakdown of the
local community
so as our
local governments local voluntary
associations the lions club and and
whatever as the local churches even as
the family breaks down people move away
people have
other unusual sorts of family
arrangements people are living on their
own more as that happens it's not that
we're no longer going to have community
we're just going to have different kinds
of community so now
the these parents in loudoun county have
much more in common with matt walsh than
they do with any member of their school
board
and i'm not saying this is a good thing
or a bad thing i'm saying this just is
politics now and so if you want to ha
undertake effective political action
you've got to recognize that and go on
that and by the way the parents of
virginia have been somewhat effective
there actually is some good news here
in fairfax county
uh two books have been removed from
the fairfax county public schools after
a parent gave a dramatic reading of the
graphic passages from some of these
books so the books are gender queer by
maya kababy
and lawn boy by jonathan
everson
according to one parent both of these
books include pedophilia sex between men
and boys the illustrations include
fellatio sex toys
um
sex with someone you love to quote
woody allen referring to individual acts
and violent nudity and so i i took a
look at some of the die i'm not going to
repeat the dialogue on this show this is
a family friendly program but this is
sick twisted perverted stuff
and these these books were available
for young children and they shouldn't be
this should not be part of any
curriculum this should not be part of
any public education
program there there is one obscene
material does not
educate you in the right way it's not
it's not essential
or edifying for your education
and two you
any educational program is going to
require limits you can't just open up
the curriculum forever you sometimes
hear that phrase from the libs when they
talk about education they say we need to
open
and expand the curriculum you can't
expand the curriculum you can't it's not
possible there's only so many weeks in
the semester there are only so many
books you can read
when you waste your time reading some
degenerate porn in schools you're you're
necessarily going to be spending less
time reading shakespeare
or some other book that would actually
be helpful for one's education
this is something else that we're going
to need to come to terms with you know
i've mentioned on this show before that
our our notion of academic freedom a lot
of conservatives defend academic freedom
now completely mistaken completely
mistaken one academic freedom the idea
that teachers ought to be able to teach
whatever they want has never existed
anywhere just about there's nothing
particularly conservative about it and
the modern conservative movement began
with a book that was making fun of this
concept of academic freedom
there are today many
even prominent conservative voices in
academia who defend academic freedom
it's a farce
far more important than
academic freedom
is uh
academic
edification i don't know i don't know
what i need i need a pithy slogan for it
here but
what you need is education that is aimed
at true freedom
right liberal education and what that
involves is not endlessly opening it up
to all this filth but
limiting
the sort of books you read to the very
best using your time wisely and
productively so you don't confuse
children and fill their heads with a
bunch of lies and filth but you fill
their heads with lots of true things the
good the true and the beautiful to help
them tamp down their appetites make
sense of their freedom this is going to
be the way forward this is when you see
those parents out there in loudoun
county saying limit the curriculum get
this crap out of the schools when you
see the parents in fairfax county saying
the same thing they are on the right
side of this they are
ironically i know we don't see it very
well today they are on the side of
freedom the limits
are the
key
to the liberty when we talk about how
liberty requires limits whether that's
in speech or whether that's in education
i think one way to bring this home is to
to make it very personal
bring it down to the level of your
relationships
bring it down to the level of your
marriage
if you want to have a good marriage an
edifying marriage a free
marriage that helps you both act like
free people
what do you do
do you say you can sleep with whomever
you want you can do whatever you want
you have no responsibility to me
whatsoever or do you say no you actually
do have responsibilities to me you can't
do whatever you want whenever you want
to do it you can't go sleep with
whomever you want
there are limits here and within that
that limit is actually going to define
the marriage and the marriage is going
to help you be
a freer
better more flourishing person
i think i've uh you know put my finger
on the scale here of which way i think
it's the latter the limits i mean that
is the definition of a marriage is that
kind of limit that then frees you up to
to flourish
i only think of this because will smith
is back in the news will smith famously
has a bad marriage he's got he and his
wife even joked about this they said bad
marriage for life you know like bad boys
for life and
it's a marriage where
i guess it's open
whatever that means and i guess they
both cheat on each other but what we've
really seen in the press is that she
cheated on him
and that he maybe was more interested in
real marriage but she was not and so
this is from an interview with gq
uh will smith just came out and he said
jaden never believed in conventional
marriage jada had family members that
had an unconventional relationship so
she grew up in a way that was very
different than how i grew up
there was significant endless
discussions about what is relational
perfection what is the perfect way to
interact as a couple and for the large
part of our relationship monogamy was
what we chose not thinking of monogamy
is the only relational perfection so
he's saying we just need relational
perfection and we do not believe that
marriage is
is relational perfection that's the
traditional ideas that yes in this man
and woman relationship the point of it
is marriage that is the stable state
he's saying no no we got married but we
don't even know what marriage is we
don't even know what marriage should be
we were trying to figure out what the
perfect kind of marriage is and so for
much of our marriage we were actually
married and we behaved like that but
then
then we decided
there was something more perfect namely
violating our marriage oath so he says
we have given each other trust and
freedom with the belief that everybody
has to find their own way and marriage
for us can't be a prison i don't suggest
our road for anybody i don't suggest
this road for anybody
but the experiences that the freedoms
that we've given one another in the
unconditional support to me is the
highest definition of love okay now he's
lost me
now he's he's saying
what we've done
by cheating on each other
and by allowing my wife to make me a
cuckold
and and allowing my wife to talk about
this on television how how shameful that
this woman would do that
that is the highest definition of love
okay well
so you think we should all do that then
no i don't think you should all do that
i don't suggest this road for anybody
hold on so you're telling me this is the
highest most wonderful definition of
love
and also you don't recommend it for
anybody anybody including you you don't
recommend it
and we of course nobody wants his wife
to go on television and say yeah i i
cuckled in my husband yeah oh yes i did
and it and and he better accept it he
better be happy you better smile and
then you see poor will smith he's on
camera he looks like he's you know about
to go jump off a pier
as he as is understandable i get it
he says this is the highest so it makes
people miserable you don't recommend it
for anybody but it's the highest
definition of love what something's gone
wrong here and it comes from this
misconception of freedom we've given
each other trust and freedom no you
haven't you can't trust each other you
lied and cheated to each other on each
other and you don't have freedom you
don't have
the freedom that a marriage gives you
the freedom
not to worry about where your wife is
when 10 o'clock it rolls around the
freedom not to worry about who's going
to be there for you who loves you pretty
baby who's going to help you through the
night
the freedom to be totally
at ease with another person who is now
actually part of you one flesh you've
lost that freedom you've surrendered
that freedom you can't have all of those
things at once
i really have great pity for these
people will smith especially will smith
but also jada who i guess was pushing it
his wife because
i think it's an honest mistake you can
make in our modern culture which is so
obsessed with the idea of emancipation
and liberation and breaking all
constraints whether it's from society
whether it's from the political
institutions whether it's from biology
itself we can't be constrained by
anything even reality even nature
and we think that this will make us
happy it won't and we think this will
make us free
it won't
paradoxically it seems to many it
actually enslaves us it makes us less
free
when we break all of those
constraints
freedom
requires
limits
speaking of limits
you're
you can see how democrats sometimes take
this leftists take this
in the other direction because
limits limits can enslave you
limits can liberate you and like the
like the meter and rhyme scheme of a
poem can liberate the poet to create
great art so too limits can constrain
you like chains and slavery
so what you need to find are just limits
you need
moderation you need justice you need
prudence these are virtues that we don't
really talk about all that much anymore
but they're they're essential to
understanding this
democrats right now are taking it the
other direction they're taking limits to
to the point of of enslaving people
enslaving people to the whims of
politicians joe biden
just received
a booster shot for his coronavirus
vaccine because the vaccine is so
effective that only months after you
receive the full vaccination cycle you
need more of the vaccine that's how
effective it is
100 effective for a few weeks and then
you need to get more of it so joe biden
is getting his booster shot reveals that
he has fairly surprisingly hairy arms
neither here nor there but it was kind
of weird to see
joe biden is taking press questions uh
this is one of the rare occasions when
he was taking questions from the press
he couldn't get up because a doctor had
a needle in his arm so it really forced
him to sit down there and the press
asked okay
joe
we've been doing this a long time now
how much longer until we can go back to
normal like what is
well i think
look
i think we get
the vast majority like just going on in
some of the
some industries it's a school
97 98
i think we're awful close and uh
but i'm not the scientist uh
i think but one thing for certain
a quarter of the country can't go
unvaccinated and us not continue to have
a problem
97 98
vaccination that's when we can go back
to normal
nine
you're never going to get that
you're never going to get anywhere near
that
97
and there's no reason even to believe
those numbers
582 days ago we were told
15 days to slow the spread
582 days ago
then flatten the curve
then find a cure and we found a cure
then
make the cure available the cure was
made available
then
get people their shots okay a lot of
people got the shots then give people
another shot because the cure was
apparently not as effective as people
said it was
then
then
then then now
98 need to get vaccinated by the way
let's say that 98 of people got
vaccinated which won't happen
they're not going to be vaccinated for
very long the vaccine doesn't last that
long that's why joe biden was just
getting the third shot
when we were told there were only two
shots that you needed who's getting the
third shot within months of getting the
second shot
so you'll never get there okay we got 98
have had their third shot and so but
unfortunately only 42 percent have had
their fourth shot so we just look look
jack
look corn poppy jack come on i'm just
come on now let's not
come on now we just need to get 99.7
need to get their 10th shot
all right jack and i'm not a scientist
but then we can get back to normal not
joking around okay come on come on man
come on man come on wake up it's just a
freaking farce at this point
these people
are just taking away
your freedom and your way of life and
your traditions
and it can happen
can happen both ways okay you can lose
your freedom
when the politicians outright come and
take it and you can lose your freedom
when you are incentivized to surrender
your freedom yourself to surrender your
freedom to your lusts and your base
passions and your appetites this is why
self-government requires that you can
govern yourself it means working on
yourself disciplining yourself and if
you want to do that i would strongly
recommend you check out
planet fitness you know in my wayward
youth i was not particularly interested
in my physical fitness okay it's just
something that i kind of ignored i never
really cared about then i had a kid
and my kid
he he's crawling around everywhere he's
getting bigger and bigger every day i
got to make sure i can lift him up it's
very important to make sure that you are
fit whether you're a young parent
whether you're just a young person in
general whether you just want to feel
good work out your stress get back to
feeling great i would strongly recommend
planet fitness join the judgment-free
zone today for just 10 bucks a month get
tons of cardio and strength equipment in
those clean wonderful clubs
with free fitness training plenty of
room to move you can go at your own pace
get back to a routine that works for you
all for just 10 dollars a month ten
bucks a month there are coffee drinks
that cost more than ten dollars go right
now check out the crowd meter in the
free pf app for the best time to visit
don't wait join any of the 2000 plus
locations today
in club online or on the app see the
club for details go check out planet
fitness today also this october
not only will backstage be live and on
stage at the famous ryman auditorium
right here in nashville
we're also giving one lucky member a
chance to win two vip tickets to get
front row seats
not just that the winner will receive a
1500 gift card to cover travel expenses
a meet and greet with the backstage
hosts and
so much more tickets for the ryman show
sold out already they sold out very very
very quickly
so thanks to everyone who signed up and
i'm sorry to those of you who were not
able to get tickets uh this is your
chance though this is your one chance to
get in on the action
you can enter when you go to
dailywire.com subscribe join one of our
membership plans with the code backstage
for 25 off your membership if you're
already a member you will be
automatically entered hurry because
tomorrow is the last day to enter we'll
be right back with a lot more
was just asked about
this this play to raise taxes on
corporations
and how if the if the corporations get
the taxes raised on them
they very well
uh will pass those
those increased costs on to the consumer
through higher prices
so gensake was asked about this very
basic economic concept she laughed it
off she said it was absurd
obviously the president's commitment
remains not raising taxes for anyone
making less than 400 000 a year there
are some and i'm not sure if this is the
case in this report who argue that in
the past
companies have passed on these costs to
consumers i'm not sure if that's the
argument being made in this report
we feel that that's unfair and absurd
and the american people would not stand
for that but i will take a closer look
at this report and get you a more
substantive response
it's unfair and absurd to think that
when you make companies pay more money
the companies make the customer pay more
money
how is
that's just that's just common sense
that's that's inevitable actually to
some degree
how do you think businesses work i guess
the biden administration doesn't know a
whole lot about this
so businesses right they they spend
money
on two kinds of things capital and labor
they spend money on stuff and they spend
money on employees
and then they
the mixture of the capital and the
employees make products and then the
consumers the customers go out and buy
those products and the products have a
price
and the price pays for the capital and
the labor and a profit margin to the
shareholders and taxes
and taxes
so now if you increase the cost of the
taxes what's going to happen
well i guess the shareholders can
receive a lower profit is that going to
happen do you think the shareholders are
going to stand for that i'm not so sure
about that
maybe a little bit but it's you know i'm
not so sure it's going to be oh do you
think that are we going to cut the the
wages of the labor i guess you could you
might run into some problems there and
then also you're going to have trouble
attracting
labor
are you going to pay less for capital x
but like for the stuff for the machines
for the capital expenditures well the
prices on that probably are not going to
change if if we're raising taxes on the
businesses actually those are probably
going to go up
so the money has got to come from
somewhere
where's the money going to come
either it's going to come from the
shareholders or it's going to come from
the customers or it's going to come from
both which seems fairly likely but the
idea that customers are going to be
completely insulated against higher
prices when you raise taxes on business
that is that is absurd
that is that is unfair and absurd to use
a phrase from gensake
and even look i don't even care that
much about economics okay i think we've
looked at our politics through too
narrow and economic lens for far too
long so i'm willing to talk about these
kinds of things and and being a little
more creative with the way we view the
relationship between the economy and the
politics
but this does require some very basic
economic literacy it doesn't which the
biden administration seems not to have
which is why prices on just about
everything you're buying right now are
going through the roof as a result of
bite inflation
even gensake though now who is doing her
best to flack for her boss
even gensake
is admitting that joe biden has not been
entirely forthright he's not been
entirely honest in the statements that
the white house has put out
notably
on afghanistan
so you remember on afghanistan
joe biden said the position of the white
house was
that
joe biden followed the advice of his top
advisors and generals in withdrawing
from afghanistan they all told him this
is what you should do and then he did it
so don't blame joe biden when things
went wrong
jensaki now admits that that was not
true
the president said his military
committees were split we now know that
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff general melanie
the head of centcom general mckenzie and
the commander on the ground general
miller
all recommended the president keep 2500
troops so who
and his military advisors told him it'll
be fine to pull everybody out i'm not
going to get in specific details of who
recommended what but i can i would
reiterate a little bit of what i
conveyed before which is that there were
recommendations made by a range of his
advisors something he welcomed something
he asked them to come to him a
clear-eyed about to give him candid
advice
what is also clear though and i'd also
note again what secretary austin said
today is that was not going to be a
sustainable over-the-long term true
presence we were always going to look at
escalating the numbers potentially going
back to war with the taliban at risking
casualties that was not a decision the
president was going to make but of
course he welcomes advice he welcomed
advice ultimately it's up to the
commander-in-chief to make a decision he
made a decision it was time to end a
20-year war
so i agree with that last part and i
think she's probably telling the truth
in that last part and i think the last
part is smart yes it is up to the
commander-in-chief to run the country
it's up to the president it's not it's
not the generals who get to run the
country nobody elected the generals it's
the president who gets to run the
country okay i agree with that
it's the first part i don't agree with
the first part
this might be the first time that the
white house has just gotten caught in an
outright lie like an outright lie they
said
that
at least some of the top advisers and
really it's even more than that
told joe biden it's totally fine to pull
out of afghanistan everyone's on the
same team and and they went out there
with that message and that message was
not true because
the top generals in our country
testified yesterday
that they told biden to keep a small
troop presence there
a couple of thousand troops the number
of troops that were there
and so this is where the credibility
really spinning is one thing or
defending the decision is another thing
i actually kind of defend the decision
too in the sense that civilians get to
get to run the country
but when you lie through your teeth to
the american people
that diminishes
your credibility and it diminishes our
trust in our basic institutions of
government
joe biden when
he
pulled out of afghanistan and the
country collapsed within days and then
american servicemen were killed and
hundreds of afghans were killed and it
was just a disastrous disastrous exit
joe biden was asked by george
stephanopoulos who was a clinton
operative okay this is a democrat
operative he was the comms director in
clinton's white house
he said hey mr president
what went wrong did you really follow
the advice of your advisors what
happened and joe biden said
i absolutely i was on board with the
advisors
your top military advisors warned
against what's drawing on this timeline
they wanted you to keep about 2 500
troops no they didn't it was split
that wasn't true
that wasn't true
they didn't tell you that they wanted
troops to stay
no not at not in terms of whether we
were going to get out in a time frame
all troops
they didn't argue against that so no no
one told your military advisor did not
tell you no we should just keep 2500
troops it's been a stable situation for
the last several years we can do that we
can continue to do that no no one said
that to me that i can recall
now notice so
what joe biden just said there is very
different from what jen saki said
happened
right now but it's not different than
what she previously said happened but
notice joe biden contradicted his
himself
within that statement
stephanopoulos said your top advisors
all said to stay
and
to keep a small number of troops in
afghanistan biden said no they didn't
they were split
and then stephanopoulos asked for
clarification and then biden rambled
incoherently for a little bit and it
didn't make any sense
and then stephanopoulos asked for
clarification again and said hold on
you're telling me no one told you to
keep the troops there
in afghanistan and he said no they
didn't
no one did hold up wait there's three
options either they
all said
keep the troops there or they were split
or they all said pull the troops out
and joe biden held two of those
positions during that one answer and it
turns out that neither of those were
true is actually the third one that
actually happened
that is a president who is either
so senile that really you do need to
invoke the 25th amendment
or
he is a liar and i actually in fairness
to joe biden i think he's just a liar i
think he lies with ease i think he had
to drop out of the 1988 presidential
contest because his lies were so
preposterous and so egregious that he
couldn't continue his campaign and i i
just think he has basically no
relationship with honesty or the truth
whatsoever but the generals
smacked him down yesterday credit where
credits do
mark milly or woke chairman of the joint
chiefs of staff he showed it thankfully
he took the pink the pink hat off you
know before he walked in he
he didn't paint his nails or anything
before he walked in to testify uh mark
milley
came in
and and
testified to say
no we wanted to keep a base level of
troops there
but i'd ask general mackenzie did you
agree to the recommendation that um
uh general miller
had
two weeks ago
senator um again i won't i won't share
my personal recommendation to the
president but i will give you my honest
opinion and my honest opinion and view
shaped my recommendation
i recommended that we maintain 2500
troops in afghanistan and i also
recommended earlier in the fall of 2020
that we maintain 4500 at that time those
are my personal views i also have a view
that the withdrawal of those forces
would lead inevitably to the collapse of
the afghan military forces and
eventually the afghan government yeah so
i understand that and uh general mili i
assume you agree with that in terms of
the recommendation of 2500
what i said on my opening statement and
the memorandum that i wrote back in the
fall of 2020 remained consistent and i
do agree with that and i'm confident
that the president heard all the
recommendations and listened to him very
thoughtfully
so very important there was this is a
little millie sandwich you had general
mackenzie on the first part and the
third part and then millie was there so
in the first part in the second part
they're both saying yes our
recommendation was keep a couple
thousand troops or a few thousand troops
in afghanistan
now the third part is important here
with mckenzie because maybe joe biden
didn't hear it
maybe joe biden never got that advice
maybe it never made it up to the
president maybe he wasn't paying
attention mckenzie says there no he was
he heard it he thought about it
he did process what we told him and he
ignored it
anyway
now i don't want to let millie off the
hook all right just because millie did a
did a good thing here i don't want to i
want to let millie off the hook don't
forget mark milly is someone who caught
when donald trump
was still the president of the united
states mark milley called china the top
generals in china and said if trump
orders an attack i'll give you a heads
up this is this is according to a new
report and
millie hasn't really denied it so i
think there's no reason not to believe
it
so millie
subverted civilian control of the
military subverted the chain of command
and now he's got an answer for that he
doesn't have a very good answer
by law i am not in the chain of command
and i know that
however by presidential directive and
dod instruction i am in the chain of
communication to fulfill my legal
statutory role as the president's
primary military advisor
after the speaker pelosi call i convened
a short meeting in my office with key
members of my staff to refresh all of us
on the procedures which we practiced
daily at the action officer level
additionally i immediately informed
acting secretary of defense miller of
sec of speaker pelosi's phone call
at no time
was i attempting to change or influence
the process
usurp authority
or insert myself in the chain of command
oh yeah then why did you call the
chinese and said you give them a heads
up if if the president of the united
states orders an attack
why why are you corresponding and
colluding with nancy pelosi why are you
leaking information
if you're not trying to use of course
you're trying to use cert power
please plea if you're gonna do it
please at least do not urinate on the
collective leg of the american people
and tell us that it's raining please at
least have the integrity to tell us what
you're doing
this is what you're seeing all around
the country from the military from
washington dc all the way to these local
governments all the way down to the
school board you were seeing a
usurpation of power a disorder of of the
system teachers administrators
politicians telling parents they can't
raise their kids the military telling
the civilian leaders the elected
officials no you don't get to run the
country you don't get to run the
military
i think we need if we want to have a
truly free country we've got to impose
limits and order on the people who are
exceeding their just bounds within our
traditional political system
we need to reign things in have a little
temperance have a little prudence have a
little bit of justice
that means for some people giving them a
little bit more freedom to move around
and for some people reigning them in i'm
michael noel's the mike knowles shall
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 2021 on the matte wall show
we talk about the things that matter
real issues that affect you your family
our country not just politics but
culture faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show